[MUSIC PLAYING]
So you hear a lot of people
are really freaked out
about this idea, this
meme of singularity.
Some call it the
"rapture of the nerds."
They feel like
technologists have
hijacked the
Christian story of God
and heaven and the
afterlife and just
translated it into the language
of electronic technology
and synthetic intelligence
and mastering the information
processes of biology so that
we can engender and engineer
our own godhood.
But I don't really think
that that's a problem.
Those religious myths that
we have been caught up
in for centuries
reflect our yearnings
to transcend our own limits.
As Ernest Becker says,
"We are gods with anuses.
With our minds, we can
ponder the infinite.
Yet we're housed in these
heart-pumping, breath-gasping,
decaying body."
So to be godly, yet creaturely
imbues the human condition
with a sort of bittersweet,
exquisite pain quality to it
that, in a way,
drives our creativity.
Our desire to transcend
all previous limits,
to transform the world
in our own image,
comes from our desire to
escape the death sentence that
makes us ultimately
food for worms.
So I think that the
singularity as a meme that
reflects the acceleration
of the human design process
to the point of achieving
a kind of infinite velocity
where everything becomes
linked with everything else,
and matter becomes mind where
we impregnate the universe
with intelligence, as
Erik Davis has written.
Today, technologists are
these ecstatic technicians
of the sacred.
They're figuring
out how awareness
works, how the self emerges.
Can we create
non-biological intelligence?
Can we create sentience
in a different substrate
that is not bound by
the limits of biology?
We are the frontal
lobes of the universe.
If we are the eyes and
ears of the universe,
if we are a way for the
cosmos to know itself,
as Carl Sagan says,
then our desire
to transcend all previous
limits is the universe's desires
therein.
So I don't think there's
anything unnatural about that.
And so for that reason, I think
the idea of the singularity
is awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]